well, I think that's exactly what I'm
saying is a person who talks to you in
this one about marching and learning and
javascript,
although really later I had to think
a little and it's the title and it
's probably more appropriate to call this
talk live learning with  javascript
well our first one our second
speaker who was francisco basic sevilla
spoke a little about the concepts this one
could also be a very
interesting talk and well well I'm going to talk to you
a little more about some of those
concepts but still and put a little bit into it
more of paper no and how can we start
with one what can be the first
steps doing machine learning with
javascript
and well well marx and lenin or deep loring
in that sense and precisely with that
I want to get to
one of the initial points to avoid
confusion not in  In that sense, I am going to
talk to you precisely about how
machine learning differs from planning
and what it is all about. Like this, we
don't often hear these concepts
but they tend to be quite confusing.
Sometimes people confuse
machine learning with deep learning, what they
think it is like.  the same or this type of
thing so quickly I think that this
image allows us to give a very very very
clear example of how
these texts are related concepts not
the first of them is the largest concept
is intelligent artificial
just artificial is a
gigantic area  Obviously,
in this field, a lot of
branches of computer science
come with many, many
implications. Not only do we talk about
machine learning as a concept,
but we also talk about this
cognitive method and many other
scientific areas that may even
be outside of  the part as
computational not within the
artificial arts we have the concept of
machine learning and what a good choice they
are probably some developers
in this in this area have heard
in recent years of this term or at
least the word just I don't think
it's like  trending, although I wouldn't
call it trending if I didn't
just mention my ideas regarding
that right now, then the match in learning
is precisely derived
from many methodologies that I wouldn't normally
be there for,
to do automation
it needs image learning in that sense,
in essence it is  Simply how you
teach it, like you teach a
machine
to learn something, we cannot leave it like this.
Obviously I know that the term is a little
more extensive, there
may be many more technicalities
here, I think it is worth mentioning that I
am not an expert in machine
learning either.  of planning but
well it still increased a little to
explore everything that is those concepts
understanding them a little in that way
then we have within a very
important concept which are neural networks
neural barriers are precisely these
tools you are going to realize later they are
even introduced  background that they are
an essential concept within this
area of ​​machine learning, precisely a
rational one, we can see it as a kind
of structure in which we say we
have an input, in this case it can be
and it is information, it is data
and we have precisely an intermediate layer
if  It can be very simple, it can be very
complex,
where the magic happens, we
cannot call it that, this whole
algorithmic part happens where we really
go from input information to
an output interpretation and this
takes us precisely to Berlin and Werning, which
is basically that.  deep learning,
how it can be translated basically is, in
essence, it does
not refer to thinking that deep
because I know because you learn
deeply, how to say it, because
machines learn deeply in
that sense that the term deep learning
there, I had read that it would be a little
more  just to make this data that
comes in be more and
more and more and more and bigger and
precisely the word deep is to
go deeper into that data to be able to
have a better car. I don't want to
mix up a bit of these terms but
it's more  or less the idea then
quickly what I mentioned is
precisely we have a set of
information and here it comes very interesting
that there is precisely a difference between
classical programming and the other between
machine learning in general
classical programming
we regularly insert data and rules if
those rules  They can be just
imagine, not a program where there
is a set of while loops and
conditionals, those are your rules in your
program and the information can be the
parameters that a function receives and
precisely this does not turn out or something in
this case answers like they can.  see
in this scheme
and then we have machine learning
where rather the input data is added
precisely what responses or what
outputs we hope to have and this type
of programs define rules for us and that is
a very important word the rules
that exist within  learning are
precisely those that define how an
algorithm learns yes and the most
classic example is a little bit the
classification of images, imagine the
typical classification algorithm where
an image comes this image let's say it is
transformed if to micro micro an English
smaller opportunities than  We
can see them as a kind of matrices, a
matrix can be seen at a mathematical level,
what we can think of as a
species with a set of
smaller data that define the entire
structure of the image in general,
so these matrices allow us to
identify what  There are colors in each
region and precisely these character algorithms
detect all those colors or
rather interpret them and thus give shape to the
understanding that there are, let's
say what patterns there are of colors in
that image, then those patterns can
form a type of face. Let's imagine the
photo with the image of a cat and if you
give that model many
images of cats, the algorithm bases its
finding on a common pattern that is
effectively this same these
characteristics in the arrangements at the level
of interpretation of colors or shapes that
are within  of the image and it is what
allows us to train a
Mazinger algorithm in large in the features we
cannot see it that way
well and for good the theory ends a little bit
one would wonder but
why deep learning and why now not
well  There really is this life,
computing chairs have been
created for quite some time, we
can even find many of the models
that are currently used and that have their
origins at a mathematical level and at
least 80, so one would wonder
why until now.  In
recent years, people
have heard so much no and it is precisely
3 to 3 particularities. The first is the
hardware that basically
today we have, for example, cloud
computing or we have
computers with much more power,
something important when training.
This type of algorithm is that
a lot of computing power is required,
so much so that the common processor,
the CPU, is not something that is
really going to give us the best
performance or that even allows us
to run
data sets or a very high data set.
large, for this it is necessary to use
smaller printers but in parallel
a parallel thinking and that is what
characterizes the gpu the
video cards precisely so I think that with
this with this we can see that
currently we can take a service in
the cloud as injured cloud computing
with a lot of gpu
that do parallel computing rent it for
a few dollars and be able to enter anything
and not something that a few years ago was
new was not possible or was much more
expensive so this has also been unique a
how to say it a first step so
that  blogging
in general marx and lenin becomes more
important then the saints and the
benchmarks that this only
refers to all the information that
has been collected in recent years and
just think about then we are talking about
that in the last fifteen twenty  years
the lord of the rise of the internet and the
popularization of social networks of
applications that collect data from
us probably on a daily basis and from
other known friends or people we do not
really know, all that
information
is extremely useful not only at a
business level but has become  very
important how people and not
only so many developers and
companies
and non-profit organizations
manipulate information precisely to
interpret certain patterns. We can
take, for example,
what is the I don't know what is the
preferred food of a region of the population
and  This has a lot of value, yes, good, to
give an example, and finally the
advances in algorithms and this also
implies not only the algorithms that
we already have since this time but
also in many of the advances at the
research level, the latest ones have been made
in the last two  decades, many of these
algorithms are not only private, they have been
made public and they are part of the
models that we can find
in libraries or in this or let's say
there in the community, it is not also something
important and well then in
general
another thing that I also want  mention
is the importance of being plr ning in
the browser well one would think that with
javascript it is not so possible to do it
is still possible not many would think is
that perhaps the performance of the language
perhaps there are not as many tools as there
could be in other ecosystems such as
for example in python
but precisely one advantage or several
advantages of having a
browser-based deep learning application is
precisely the reduced costs
abroad. This does not mean that you do not
have to process
your entire algorithm on a server, but rather
that you can do it on the client side and
it is an advantage that this precisely gives us
libraries such as tensor flow
laws that allow us to have models not
only trained at night and
using a server application but
on the client in the browser you can
have your algorithm  Running on Google
Chrome, as we are saying, we
have that accessibility and it
is even possible to run these same
types of rhythms on a mobile phone,
so it gives us a lot of
versatility, then there is the low
latency interference that comes a
little more to the reference that we don't
have to go to.  ask the server for any
information and finally we have
effective sorry we have the
instant selection of the gpu which is basically that we do
not depend on using a
gpu in a cloud service but it is within
the same browser not
obviously data deprivation
refers to that one  You will not have to
follow the browser, for example, to
do face recognition. In this case,
we are going to identify, whether it is some
feeling or we are classifying
images, all the information that passes
would be through the client, so there
we are guaranteed security with the
data and finally the  which are instant
in although being browser-based applications
allow us to share a url
and anyone, with the
internet song, can access them
and well, let's get to the good thing, I
just want to talk to you a little bit about
transa flotillas,
it is a library built by Google
based on the  popular tensor flow that
but well we must remember that tensó
flow is built mainly for
python or in python this then we can
say that it is a kind of portal
because there are many of the models that
are already trained the tensor flow
are ready here among those logics and
The magic that allows us to have the
consortium you arrive running
effectively is javascript obviously as
the language both in client and
server
through the server because the night is used
just to put but train
models right there even tensor
project offers a cdn
with models  pressed we don't have to
do it ourselves and one will wonder
how it happens in all these
gpu operations within the client
because precisely using web 'www which is
a technology that is precisely to
render graphics in the browser
here is an interesting section and that is because
there  It was being said that webgl
was not the best idea because it was not so
optimal and that made the applications
weigh much more, they will consume much more
memory when running in
production
and they are looking for alternatives to
change webgl, maybe there are other
alternatives in  in that sense we couldn't
think of I don't know if I remember if it was
good, it got drunk on the style but
several alternatives in the future that could
be better than using any one
directly but for now it works with
this graphics library
and well before starting with the
code  I want to mention just three
very quick concepts by Iván and you know
the word tensor, which is nothing more than a
simple computing term to
define an arrangement with many
inputs. Imagine a network with many
inputs. That is a normalization tensor
that also comes from the world.  Of
the two data from the databases,
which is a statistical term that
refers to putting a set of rules
on the data, it is when it is required to
normalize data, it refers to giving
rules to the data, well, and they return to the one
that I explained, they are not  these models that
allow us to have this
own algorithm logic to give an
interpretation to the fatah that comes in and
obtain the output as we expect and
through this the rules are defined
well then we are going to move very quickly
to the code
well to begin we are going to
quickly go a  example so you can
see how easy it is to start with cons
blocks we are going to use in that sense
only
the first model that is based on
well it is called mobile net or val net it is
one of the most popular within the
flow tensor you arrive
and it helps us to
image classification and then look at the first step
and in fact this comes directly from the
transaction documentation is that we
can use all these cdn models
so here we have here we have these
three imported models well the first one
is obviously in making it
three by three  Of the models we
bring us mobile net and a classified
alcaine n which I will not go into much detail
because it may be a little
mainly for people who have never
heard of this but here nn is a
classification algorithm based on
data
grouped precisely francisco
previously in his com  gave a
small explanation of what k nn was and the
classification before grouped so
it is more or less the concept ok and
here we have simply
defined these these small labels
are four buttons in this case
labeled with with these from irish and a
video that  we are going to allow access to the
video tag that allows us to access
the webcam
in that sense ok so down here
we connect and movilnet and that is where
the interesting thing comes if well molinet contains
within itself
this code that in fact I am going to leave it
there in hip  hop I already created a repo in case you
want to take a look at it and well I'm going to
explain papi ximo how this behaves
just here what happens is we
have to sit in this
main function which is the function to the asynchronous function
so what happens here  It is that
the model is loaded if through mobilenet,
in this case we are pulling it
from the cdn, we must not forget that and
then praise the scan, which is precisely
this was precisely the tensioner, so
take the image data if this  It is
a clean biooptimum within
just days that allows us to read, let's say,
what is in the video that comes in in
real time and then we have in this case
an asynchronous function that is precisely out
of time and what it does is simply
capture
the image  in this case felipe
frame does it and he does it frame by frame of the
webcam in that sense and then we have
right here this variable here is
activation that is what allows us to
say to use the knn classifier that
receives two parameters in this case one
image that the image is each image
captured by let's say this variable
through the gap and a parameter true
that is in the documentation in this
sense and then to this classifier
which is a variable that is out here
that we define where we define in the
creation of  Our knn classifier
is read through the time method, if you
notice, it must receive a parameter that
chooses side and in this case it receives
activation and class and class and from there we
will see it later, it will be
precisely
the button in this case that  We have
marked here, we have four different ones. Let's
continue with the code. Ok,
this is the method here. It is very
important. What this post does is
free memory. What happens with these
methods is that when they run the client,
because let's remember that this is nothing more than a
client.  On the server,
what happens is that they use a lot of GPU,
well, they require heavy use of GPU,
so they consume quite
a lot of resources, so this post
helps us free up memory every time
one of the tensors is loaded, just so
as not to generate a  love illica
in that sense
ok here we have some that telemadrid where we
select the four labels and
add one from landis to have it arrive
through click and what it does is
call the
arc shampoo event and receives exactly what
I mentioned to the former field and remember
that this event here receive air classes
which in this case is how
each button is labeled 0 1 2 and 3
in that order and then we define an
infinite light so that the
image classifier in this case rather so that
framework frame are being captured each
image of the video while it continues
running yes then through the
classifier the number of classes is
greater than 0 what we do is take an
image by taking a capture from the
webcam in this case what I am telling you
is showing us in multiple images
that occur  in a way
like in easy real time and then
we have again the activation variable
that is set here is very similar to what
happens up here with activation which what it
does is load one of the models
in this case which in this case is the
same  dance with its parameters where
the image comes from and is string and
finally what we do is
to launch the result based on
the prediction that the
classifier makes us and what it preaches what it does is
receive a parameter which in this case is
the preloaded model and returns it in
this result and then finally
we have in an array of classes where,
in this case, it is the Alavés and we return
through the label with show, it is over
here where we are going to take the
results from the part  above
with this string which is a singh template
of my prediction and its ability and
right here the values ​​are printed
or well the values ​​are going to be shown in the
dom which are each label that exists in
the class and the probability which in this
case is  the value of the result that
the prediction returns to us and here you can
see the same thing is repeated every time we load
a model and asset and activate it we
have to not forget for a trigger and
remember that this helps us to be with
memory release and this is  a method
that is in extreme extension that tells
tensor flow to basically take one
of the frames of the video in that sense and
we execute the up function then with
these small files well this one in
this small one
we have our model only in the
client yes and let's go  Let's see the result
ok we're going to enter
chrome
l
ok
this is our file called index
we open it with chrome
and well here we just wait a little
here
no
ok here as you can see it allows us
access to the camera is but that way no
no  It will be slower than normal and the
computer is containing a lot of
ram
but wait a little we
can see how to inspect for the moment
because it is happening
ok in charge the model is just waiting for it to
generate the frame here the camera
regularly does not work it has been slow
I think  I don't know if I already connect to the
internet which I don't think
is probably the ram consumption
I'm not very sure
[Music]
ok access the camera we take the model
there it is as you can see here I have the
four buttons that I mentioned clicked
on  these buttons can read
an image for example in the a I'm going to
save my face for example then that
would be the model ah yes I can take
multiple multiple frames here the ideal
is to take a lot of frames of an
object yes and then for example I could
move from the image
and place my phone for example here
and save it
as a good position save it
position b or rather in model b
then I can take the object maybe
a notebook
in this one we have these strings it has
models
let's wait for it to react to this and  in the
model they can pay for anything else we
could talk about I don't know
let's put for example
what
I don't know I don't know look how pretty they are but I
'm not very sure let's put it in English
and save the data of this image
so this this model will be  they give
four pieces of information four types of entries in
this case it's me it says well if you can
look at it here is my reflection that because
well it's me axes where we keep all
the photos of in this module of this
model they are I'm in group a in
group b
We put the phone away so if I
move and put this object, it's going to be to
see if, as you can see,
if we put a notebook or something similar,
we can do what happens if we try
here, I have another book in my hand. Maybe
look at the prediction, that one is correct,
then.  If the airplane mouse is working well,
here I don't know how it's going to
work, but let's see if it's
correct. There, it's kind of
confusing. If it's a smartphone, it's not the
mouse, but well, there you can see the level,
so this is the one, that's one of
the  very fast applications that
mobile net has is a model that
no longer has to worry about
training on the server but can
work directly in the browser
ok so I want to go back to the slide very quickly
ok
so sorry here there was a lack of value
here you should say  mobile net
that is the first algorithm and the second
is coco it is that coco ssd is an example
that I want to show you very quickly it
is also an image classification algorithm
but well but this one has
the particularity that it does not
directly classify an image through  of the
frame but it does it with objects
so better said this is purely
an image classification and this is
a good object classifier like
this one has the characteristic that it
is already preloaded but it already has
several models prepared, for example
here you can see
that there are several  objects in an image and
it is able to detect with some
confidence we can tell with a hundred
percent how close an
object is so I want to
show you a very quick example of what
I just built for you
remember that your examples
will also be in hip hop  so I want to
share that with you well let's go quickly
to html objects here I have it here
and we can skip this very quickly it's
simply an html that has
some presentation texts here
for you this and the important thing is
this this section where I have a button
to  enable the web here and I have the
video that you remember as the
previous case is to preload the webcam and
never forget in this case for speed
and simplicity what I do is just
show you how to connect it
from the cdn but you can use
npm  or some other
bojan perhaps as a package manager to
install the dependencies directly,
just let them know that it can be done
through the cdn. In this case, if you
realize, we load tensor laws, which is the
general library, and each model is
loaded separately in this case.  the
model is coco
this is what I was talking about and
here is connected our writing which is
our script for the detector ok there
is not much time to explain this
is all this all this code but let's go through
the most important parts
important in this part up here
is something general to be able to read each
content of the domino in this case what
allows us to access what Carlos is going to do, let's
press the okay button now and the webcam,
which is the one in this case the video
ok is  The small function here is what it
does is verify if we have access to the
web, or rather the webcam, and if we have
the permissions to access it or not, if we
have them, then we obtain that
information and enable access to the
web, which is not so much  about the
giorgi tensor it is something internal
from something picking to be able to access
the browser permissions,
probably some of you will already
know it and here comes an
important thing here I told you precisely
that it is where the webcam is enabled and
the classification begins and what it does
is  receive an event, this function that is
called in the search that in ebook am is
executed here with the click of the button that
enables the webcam
and what it does is through the target, which
is what is in that because it is in
this button.  make a paddle in
this case well well we will
click on the button to disappear or something
from the very characteristic dome and
here comes these parameters so
that I am my area where the video is enabled
and activate it and activate the style of
the webcam this is very important to do
before capturing the models because
this is what we need to do is read
what is happening through that video
to be able to load to be able to take
change each frame of this case of the
video no ok and then we have the
creditcard webcam function that  What it does is
start classifying each frame of the
spin as I mentioned,
the code probably doesn't look so pretty here, let's
say well, I had it all the time to
clean it but you can see a little here
what happens, not what it does is take the
model  defined above
remember that I was here yes with books
of various minutes yes of course well the
fact is to have every little time so I
explain with this what we do is
take each prediction we take a
percentage of each frame of this
prediction and if it occurs it is drawn
directly  and finally what
we do in this part is load the
model and in this case coco ssd that I know I
mentioned this through the
parameters that are passed here is like the
color of the model so I want to
show you running this
very fast function that takes  to this program in
oviedo 7 ml
we opened again and
with this you can find just some cards with
tense flow I say some because they are only the ones
that the coco ssb model has which
are quite a few the building and finally
how would this one look when if you like to
run  Once you have found it, you
have the active client,
you can find a receiver very
similar to this one, it will tell you the
percentage of each object and then that's
it.